this show is brought to you by the cash
at the number one finance app at the App
Store you probably know cash app is the
easiest way to send money to your
friends but cash app does way more than
that folks cash app also comes with the
cash card a free debit card that comes
with boosts which are like instant
rewards for shopping at the places that
you already love you can get up to ten
percent off on your entire purchase at
door - and even every time you shop at
Whole Foods Target and more I have that
card ah yeah I move money over to it
whenever we travel for comedy I use that
incident my debit cards nobody gets my
number oh stop making this about you
cash app is also the easiest way to try
and grow your money their new investing
feature
unlike investing tools that forced you
to buy entire stairs of stairs of shock
they're called shares of stock cash app
lets you instantly invest it as little
or as much as you want have you invested
any company spends no no I don't do that
oh well you should because this way you
can still own a piece of any stock with
just one dollar I'm also excited to be
working with the cash app to support one
of my favorite organizations called The
Trevor Project when you sign up for cash
app and use the promo code Whitney
that's my name if you don't know that
we've got an issue not only will you
instantly receive $10 but the cash app
will also donate $10 to The Trevor
Project huge huge huge amazing
organization that provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ youth across America
are you for that or against that that's
it who are they they're gonna give you
money and give my understand people yeah
I love that
download cash app from the App Store
today tada
[Music]
are we going first podcast episode share
these headphones I guess I have to look
at me
oh no I'm doing a podcast boys look at
me cuz it's my first episode of China
sad sultry hey everybody I started a
podcast is this your version of a sultry
voice yes that was sexual you okay I
need to stop doing a fake voice I'm
trying to do something I'm trying to
impress you guys I started a podcast you
did it I never thought this would had
never thought this day would come
nine years only took me nine years to
start a podcast I feel like I just
decided I think this is gonna stick
should do this I never started a podcast
before because I was too busy doing
other people's podcast I didn't have
time to do my own I was a professional
podcast guest and it also took me a
while because I wanted to wait until I
found someone to do it with and still
looking still looking for the perfect
co-host no Rihanna said no she's busy
Shane Dawson was unavailable so I asked
Benton I feel like I need to tell
everyone Benton used to be my assistant
so he knows me very well and he can call
me out on my shit used to be very hard I
want to clear very hard the only job I
ever cried having only one because I was
trying so hard and couldn't get it right
well it's nothing you couldn't get it
right you were a very good assistant and
I was like confused because I kept
missing meetings and I was like what's a
friend I was a great friend I was a bad
assistant well you said something really
made it click into place it's when you
finally told me that you're dyslexic and
I'm also dyslexic so to dyslexic people
trying to run a calendar you ever seen
two clowns trying to do anything you
were just like sick I'm Dyslexic so I
was like this won't work so I decided to
promote you to be the person that fights
with me on my podcast great because
you're not scared of me I'm not scared
of you and I want you to know
not scared of you but I do respect you
so that's good okay please stop picking
at your nails on our first time my nail
can I see my hand it's sickening
disgusting
you're being disgusting on our first
episode I also think that where I'm weak
you're very strong and when you're
strong I'm really weak like we have were
the wind beneath my wings but we have
the rights to that definitely not just
don't say it just say it Nikki oh here's
I need to tell you guys a couple things
about Benton he also yawns sometimes my
kids so rude
he'll yawn out of nowhere but he insists
it's because of his asthma you go to one
professional meeting in front of all of
your agents and yawn and all of a sudden
it's a problem he went to a meeting with
me and was yawning the entire time and
it was not Yanni
I was nervous and holding my breath okay
in which case I had to then take an
oxygen to not pass out an oxygen take in
oxygen or take on oxygen
Benton also has a speech impediment and
I stand firmly by it I thought you had a
speech coach she died in a tornado
that's a fact it's really sad it was
traumatizing to the whole town how do
you die in a tornado I wasn't there but
I was like a cartoon from Wizard of Oz
she was like whisked away a tornado yeah
I guess so your speech therapy just
stopped after that no I did a little
more but I'd never took I I have a
little bit of a speech impediment to
sometimes my brain moves faster than my
mouth and my mouth can't catch up that's
my use like my dad how dare you I have a
speech impediment you have a speech
impediment this should be an amazing my
cast
I want like hard-asses I know don't do
that yes I'm best edr what does I hear
some or whatever
do you I I think you might have invented
that actually add some more old specials
oh I know I hits a lot of my specialist
I yell and hiss I like it I think
because I put my mouth too close to the
microphone which I think it's cuz you're
a pit viper excuse me you ever seen you
eat eggs like a snake I don't have you
seen me either
yeah when we were on set fun fact I was
also a PA I won a Whitney shows and I
had to feed her eggs like a lizard
can you play how dare you that none of
that's true I'm I'm suing you for
blasphemy finally I do think though
we're gonna be good because we're gonna
balance each other out we disagree on a
lot of almost everything frankly we have
absolutely nothing in common first I've
heard of it and I feel like we are into
different things like I know a lot about
neurology you know a lot about shooting
guns off cows mm-hmm you're very good at
it I am very into therapy you are very
into YouTube same thing this is
millennial therapy I'm very into
psychiatry and you're very into
astrology also same thing I did not even
close to the same thing we're setting a
boundary right now in this podcast and
that is that no no verbally and
emotionally abusing me
by using horoscopes and my sign she
wants direct abuse what I don't want I
dragged abuse then you'd be like oh
that's such a Virgo thing to say none of
that on this podcast listen listen
astrology has been around for 2400 years
okay a long time okay and I understand
that's not only something - it was so
his racism doesn't mean it's a good idea
Babylonians invented racism I'm just
saying just because something's old
doesn't mean it's true and not that I
don't think astrology is true I actually
think that astrology has some valid
points but not because of the reasons
that you think I think it's fun oh of
course it is fun but it's I think that
someone's birthday had an indelible
effect on their psyche not because of
the moon and the stars are where they
were placed but because where your
birthday lands and the other holidays
around it leaves a mark like everything
I can see everyone I know that is a
Capricorn their whole thing is that
they're like pragmatic and patient and
practical but you have to because your
birthday was in January or late December
and you're competing with other major
holidays you have to be practical
because no one wanted to come to your
birthday you had to have a practical
approach and yet to be very patient
because no one's get you presents member
this Capricorn which also explains why
they're miserable and money-hungry well
yeah I mean think about it remember
those people that would be like come to
my birthday party January 6 everyone
we're done we just celebrated for two
weeks we don't have any money left
you're not getting a present you're
getting a bath bomb that my aunt gave me
that I used I think it's nice you got
invited to birthday parties I didn't go
to them in January cuz nobody did so
that I think is what forms you as an
astrological sign think about a
Capricorn so late December right yeah
they had to share a birthday with Jesus
Christ that'll make you real that'll
make you real patient and real practical
real fast am i right I mean you're right
you're right about that but also give me
another sign tell me anything
when's Pisces Pisces is Pisces is
February 20th through March 20th yeah
all my friends at are Pisces they're
like I'm so sensitive they're so
sensitive yet because your birthday was
over spring break so you probably got
cheated on on your birthday yeah but
they're all psychics listen they saw
that coming I think they are opposed to
me they're opposed to be another thing
or a speech impediment I was just an
accident it was you're not nervous I'm
not nervous
what are you a Taurus I'm not you're not
nervous what are you a tourist I am a
tourist like cher in a Dale OH
Megan Fox oh hey girl it's interests and
what's all the beautiful people what's
the other one Virgo virgos get a very
bad rap it's you but there is an
explanation for why people that are born
in September have a strong worth a work
ethic not worth ethic the opposite see
that's my speech impediment I conflate
words that close to each other I just
mess up all words oh great this is gonna
be a real hit my guess is a hit already
but know when you're born in September
that means your birthday is when the
first day of school is basically my
birthday was always the first day of
school you have to be perfectionist you
have to be organized in micromanage II
because your first day of school was
your birthday my birthday presents were
like Trapper Keepers of course I'm
organized my parents in have anymore
yes I got school supplies as birthday
gifts so it makes sense it's also I
guess I would play into the fact that
they're like perfectionist and warriors
and overly critical that's a very school
like thing
yeah because also I had to make friends
on my birthday it was like hi I'm
Whitney it's my birthday how we
so I feel like I had to overcome and say
a lot also September kids they're either
the oldest in the class or the youngest
in their class which means they were
held back know just because how dare you
it means that like you're either gonna
have a superiority complex because
you're the oldest in your class or an
inferiority complex and overcompensate
by being a perfectionist and working
hard because you're the youngest in your
class that was me I was insecure that I
didn't know as much as everyone else I
was pretty I'm I'm on to something
yeah I mean it makes sense what you're
saying and I think September kids virgos
kind of know in the back of their head
that they might be a mistake because we
were all conceived in December over
eggnog our moms were pickled with eggnog
when we were conceived celebrating the
Lord yeah sure the birthday of the Lord
I mean I just think that sometimes it's
fun to believe in something
oopy and spooky I agree I agree but I
don't know I just like to explore the
other reasons why that it would make
sense like the psychological reasons
like the big reason that I think people
like astrology is it fits great into
mean culture its quick its yeah that's
relatable but also it's a really good
way for like girls to culture their
crazy and not get in trouble it's a nice
to say my boyfriend you know my
boyfriend's on asshole he's a Leo and
then you don't unpack any trauma yeah
but yeah that's the other thing
don't take relationship advice or
medical advice from astrology memes I
know people that are like my car the
brakes don't work Mercury's in
retrograde bitch get your brakes checked
go to a mechanic I have a headache for
three weeks Mercury's in retrograde no
go to a doctor I think it's fun until
you start taking medical and
relationship advice from it putting
blinders on around the person you're
dating because of your size it's more
fine he's a Leo of course he's gonna
cheat yeah he's a Leo well although you
know Kylie Jenner's a Leo and she
dressed her daughter up as herself so
I'm just saying that's a little on the
nose what does that mean you have her
self centered so Leos birthday was in
August and they didn't have to compete
with any holidays people actually came
to their birthday parties on decide
some things well you solid you didn't
start off being like the original
psychology though just to be clear when
you were born it was where they
determine what you're gonna do in the
village you love talking about villages
I do yeah so it's how they kinda
determine what your role is gonna be
who's they
Babylonians and then 300 years later
made its way over to Egypt which is
ruled by Greece and that's why it has
such a heavy Greece influence yeah how
do you know this I can read can you
yeah just it takes me a little longer
okay we have to talk about our hub
coming guess there's more stuff I'm
gonna want to be doing and the opening
of the show I'm gonna do like a reading
of the day a word of the day because the
podcast is called good for you and I
want everything on the show to be good
for you I want people to walk away like
learn and stuff and you smoothy's people
just learn a bunch of stuff about
astrology and Babylonians from Benton
our first guest is I'm just beside
myself with excitement yeah I'm thrilled
yeah I may cry again second job I've
cried during his show before it's a
little show you might have heard of it
it's called shits Creek Dan levy is here
he's our first guest he was my first
choice for first guest which might a bit
of mistake because I am not entirely
sure all of this equipment is even
working okay cannot wait dan levy is
neck I think the first thing we should
start with is do we are we best friends
yes yes can you say I think actually
hold you with like life problems at this
point how did this happen I don't know
don't know you
there was a bit honestly there's time in
your home don't know you some big oak
door was just opened and I feel like
mm-hmm
that was it how did we I feel like I've
known you for quite a long time okay
because I have a friend named Dan levy
yes I have canceled him replaced him
with you Dan levy can I have one of my
father Dan levy and I met at an audition
don't even speak of him okay he's dead
to me everyone calls me levy no so
racist III don't know what it is I mean
there's multiple there's levees and
levees so I guess yes it anti-semetic
i I don't know to be determined you know
in the comments section explore and
really sort of honor the the different
shades of levy Levy Levite there was a
couple times that I texted you thinking
it was Dan levy thank God it wasn't too
embarrassing I have texted myself like
life notes like remember to be kind to
yourself and sent it to Dan levy yeah
because you send yourself reminders I
send myself reminders either to remember
something to think about something
sometimes it's like little life
affirmations like I can't remember to
breathe and be kind to yourself and you
send it text back from levy saying okay
you okay is that I'm assuming that
wasn't for me but if it is I will
breathe and take care of myself thank
you so much I have done that many times
because in Hollywood where we reside
mm-hm
there is something called like your team
right yeah your team a collection of
people yeah when you win the MU next
year you will thank your team do you
have your Emmy speech did you work on
lighting no let's talk about who we're
gonna lose to next year more accurate
what was your plan for an Emmy fact that
you didn't win is crazy to me
I think that's very kind I have never
that kind I've never been more excited
to lose to anybody than Phoebe Waller
bridge yeah and fleabag it was a perfect
that and veep to me are two sort of
touch tones just touch tone that's not a
word look touch make you nervous and
that's okay let's turn we're very close
you don't have to be nervous around
anywhere I tried to use a bit like of my
word you had a didn't whirl there are
two fun shows that I like a lot let's
simplify that concept okay and when I
started out making my show I told our
entire team I want this show in a
perfect world to live on the same sort
of shelf as veep yep that was the big
mandate so to get the nomination in
veep's last year was like a really big
thing for me I also I have a
qualm okay I'm known for my qualms sure
I think that there should be an
understanding of the level of difficulty
when to show a shot and it should either
be in a different category or it should
be clear your show had a lot less money
to spend then as these Canadian dollars
per episode okay okay
Game of Thrones where they get four
hundred thousand dollars an epic million
four hundred thousand dollars it's four
hundred thousand dollars a second I
actually haven't seen Game of Thrones
and it really pisses people it has four
hundred million and you guys I won't you
don't have to tell me your budget mm-hmm
touchy no less than that and I feel like
there should be a rating not only for
like parental advisor whatever so
everybody knows how much money best
comedy under two million dollars but or
you should people should just understand
the level of difficulty they could
probably understand it just by looking
in my tired eyes and Haggard face how
dare you I mean yeah it's it's quite
extreme I mean for us we were in this at
the Emmys we were in this like state of
shock I think because it is an
impossibility if you were to like lay
out the pieces of our show financially
what we're working with my tired eyes my
lack of sleep it doesn't like naturally
lead to an Emmy nomination that's not
sort of the natural evolution of it
because of everything you overcome so
needless to say we were all like walking
dead people but like really excited to
be there but zombies we were all stunned
I'm obsessed with how to get hindsight
right now okay right like we can always
get hindsight yeah when we have
hindsight like thank God that breakup
happened because then I met this person
or thank God I got fired from that job
because it opened the store to this
other job do you think in any universe
the fact that you had such a tight
budget to work with
at all informed your character who was
struggling with money also because
general edge and yeah and like agitation
and lack of patience there David
is so real it's so real and it's so
intense it's the most intense and I do
feel like David and what I was doing
behind the scenes were vibrating at a
very equal sort of level and I was
channeling a lot of the in intense
responsibilities and like I could feel
it oh good I feel hopefully that's like
not a painful thing to experience but
rather very real to the character it
felt like when they call to action you
were right there you were your
frustration about money maybe was right
there there were three weeks this year
where I was living off of one and a half
to two hours sleep at night and we would
wrap the show I would come home at about
eight o'clock right until two o'clock
and then get picked up at five o'clock
and it was I want to say three straight
weeks by the end you don't want to know
me yeah it is this is why I think that
there should be a reading that says how
many hours of sleep this showrunner got
on every episode I think all you have to
do is like Google's showrunner and fall
out and you will inevitably find an
encyclopedia of examples of how intense
the pressure is and how hard it is to
balance the pressure I mean we say this
it's entertainment we're having fun you
trust me it's there are things that are
far more high-pressure but you know I
think for me I like to I'm a
perfectionist I want to do my best I
want to put things out there that I can
stand behind and that I love and that I
believe in so for me the pressure is
sort of self-imposed I have a question
about Moira Rose sure shoot and I know
people ask you about this a lot I just
was so fascinated because I've had to
deal with notes coming in about women's
characters and they have to be good
mothers and they have to be likeable and
we have to root for them and they have
to be good at their jobs and I've seen
so much of that Mormon Rose arguably
besides David Rose
the greatest character on television
currently none of those things yeah it
was so charming and lovable did you ever
have to balance any of that or get in
the weeds on is this too far as this
dicey do we want to see a woman doing
this no I think because so much of that
character came from Catherine herself
and the conversations that we would have
in terms of the parameters of where the
character lives and how far we can push
her sometimes doesn't say that her
daughter sitting there oh I mean and in
more than one time an episode we'll just
won't touch her when she said 100%
won't touch the kids like generally if
she doesn't have to but there's a power
to it yeah there's a boundary that's
been said and you know part of it I
think is just because there's been
inherently the separation they've all
lived very separate lives and money
really separated these people and made
them feel like things were going well
when in actuality the removal of that
money made them realize that nothing was
going well and that they had a lot to
learn
interpersonally but that character has
been the greatest joy to write and to to
be a spectator for to watch Catherine do
what she does with that I mean it is a
masterclass in comedy I am basically
only doing this podcast to make enough
money to finance the crows have eyes the
actual production I am not joking oh why
can't we make it here's the a shot kasha
we're making it I will get a Kickstarter
going I don't care don't think I haven't
thought about it keep thinking what I
have to sit down what to make too much
money I don't want to turn into David
the idea of what that movie could look
like I will write it for free great
let's sit down and let's brainstorm this
is knock all your other projects do it
it would be kind of a genius I'd never
say meta I'm so sorry that I'm saying no
you'd have to really move it forward and
show it's basically a prop to the show
we can give you a role mm-hmm you can be
in it I'm happy to beat you in it yeah
but it has to be made yeah and
problem is how do you make that movie
with when you're being paid in like old
tree leaves and creative we're gonna do
a patreon I don't know I don't know
exactly what they are how do you feel
your relationship has changed around
money while making the show because I'm
obsessed with a show that is about money
to me that is like the last taboo
talking about money it's not really sex
anymore it's really money and the show
the shows that I always love to her
about that like Roseanne rest in peace
and has your relationship to money
changed at all the show has been the
most emotionally cathartic experience I
never saw coming
hmm I didn't when we started the show
the intention was to always sort of peel
back the layers on who these people are
and hopefully lead them to a realization
that love is the most important form of
currency and that money does not solve
these problems and in the case of this
family money had been a hindrance in
terms of them realizing things about
themselves they were able to put up
walls they were buying you know clothes
that really armored themselves from who
they were realizing that acting it
writing it was was yeah incredibly
cathartic have you gotten any good money
advice I love good money advice well my
mom is the first one that is that is
there to tell me don't mess this up wait
I do not f it up say this is I mean my
parents since I was 16 my I was I think
I was 15 is that even legal to do what
well I was at at Bar Mitzvah this is in
terms of like a money like money
philosophies from a very early age was
at a Bar Mitzvah they dropped me off in
front of gap kids which is my which was
my job of choice at the time and said
don't come home until you have a job
application from gap kids from gap kids
and I chose Gap Kids because I didn't
want to work at the real gap where I'd
have to run into kids my own age
work at the cap Oh what I see where did
he work there was some disdain for cap
but I will Wow there was some lost
another sponsor one thing unbelievable I
came out of that experience with a lot
of cranberry turtlenecks so I bet the
fault you had to do the folding and I
absolutely had to learn all of it but my
mom there was a point in my life where
my mom was like okay get a job you want
those clothes yeah you're gonna buy
those clothes yeah oh you're gonna find
a way that gets you a very big discount
on those clothes and that's what it was
from 15 on I never got any kind of
financial advice as a kid I feel like
women in general like we don't get told
how to save money or change tires or any
of that shit I recently got some very
good money advice which was to open a
separate bank account for your taxes so
for me I used to like when I first
started making money I was like oh my
god I have all this money yay and then
tax time came and I couldn't afford to
pay my taxes and I was like ah because I
thought the amount of money in your bank
account was the amount of money you had
is that never happened you
well my uncle is an accountant how dare
you unbelievable so that's cheating I've
always been in very good hands
uh-huh and my aunt at the actually when
I was when I got my job at MTV which was
my first like big gig was in Canada it
was not that big no it's not daily not
rolling in cash but it cost me money
does like did you guys just invoice me
for the work I just did yeah absolutely
not four years of work Oh a lot of
people have questions about Degrassi but
we'll get to that okay my aunt set up a
savings account for me and forced me at
the time it was like one of those
prepaid savings accounts where you like
link it to your bank account and every
paycheck it will extract money right in
yes into the savings account and I came
out of MTV and decided to head to LA for
a little bit and had savings Wow good
for her love her I opened a new bank
account were if you're making hundreds
you put 30 dollars in the bank account
right away you never have like see money
that you don't
you get to spend big game-changer
another thing that I did a business
manager explained to me that this is
gonna be different for everybody but the
price of something basically double it
cuz with taxes everything cost twice as
much because that's how much you have to
earn to be able to afford it sad is a my
mom philosophy for sure she was like you
have to earn double and know that half
of your income is going away anyway so
if a shirt is $100 it's $200 because you
have to earn 200 to be able to afford a
hundred that's what I was told growing
up anytime I wanted something my mom
would say you know that sweater your dad
has to earn double in order for you to
have that sweater and I'd be like well I
don't want that I loved her it was like
I was like I felt guilt and I think
that's part of why I have been working
since 15 with this like almost manic
desire for independence elite financial
independence because I have been sort of
raised to to know that anything I wanted
as a kid my dad had to work double time
for me to have oh god I never wanted my
dad to have to do that he already had to
go off by himself and like leave his
family to like do shoot a movie didn't
take a pay cut to work with you you know
all of this resulted in probably the
biggest financial loss of his life that
doesn't matter it's all about rotating
our darts imitating life you'll have to
have my dad on next and ask him about it
but we did have a lovely seven years of
our lives together that are now
documented on camera do you insane have
you gotten in any serious fights or any
disagreements like major yeah I mean I
think you're its business so you get
into disagreements and for me it was
like in the early days I'd be like
honestly just listen to me like it was
but then I realized oh this is actually
a business right I'm no longer a
teenager take the emotion out I am glad
like what they call professional yeah in
the way that I handle this but no I mean
I think anytime you work with someone
that you're really close with there's
always the lines that are blurred
between how do I react to this situation
in a way that Ben
it's both of us right and how do I stay
professional and I it's tough because
it's an intimate relationship you're I
mean he's my dad I'm his son like of
course you're gonna want to speak in
different ways but I think the thing
that sort of kept us going was just
putting the show first above anything
else in any discrepancy at the end of
the day whatever idea best serviced the
show was the idea that went I also get
super obsessed when people are like mega
successes about embarrassing things that
happen in their career before like any I
see myself as just like such like when
people like you've done so much I'm like
okay well you haven't heard about the
time that an agent at ICM told me that I
wasn't pretty enough to ever star in a
show like is that my face to my face and
is that agent employed still unclear but
here's the kind of agent where if he
picking at your face and none of that
tracks for me and I'm not saying that
just because I'm here doing the podcast
you're eligible it doesn't matter what
your face looks like second of all
there's so many I mean continue doesn't
he's I don't agree with them but there
used to be a time when guys could just
say that to 22 year old girls like it
said like he said I'm quirky and
whatever and then no I know but raging
but I love telling these stories because
I think it's so important that people
see that like you have to go through
some of that bullshit in order to get
something else and everybody's got those
embarrassing horrific don't moralizing
stories that I ever done like a Lifetime
movie
I have not why well I feel like that's
sort of in the embarrassing sort of
Canon of people's yeah that's like no
that's why I haven't done one but oh I
have I guess oh how did it go like your
Christmas one oh no I know but it was I
played a parent killing wait um murderer
whose can you google that nope we don't
need to google it although I did just
say it out loud so I guess anyone we
don't need to go there do we have a
screening a special screening let me
continue
with what this character okay he was a
the movement well the movie was called
cyberstalker
oh no we haven't yeah we don't need a
trailer why am I in the trailer for an
Emmy they put you he likes you
it has very many more view no it does
not I'm no please okay sorry anyway I
was in a wheelchair for the movie okay I
was a parapet presumed paraplegic so I
was in a wheelchair I had an addition
for this part I did in a wheelchair like
crushing it was a full drama humtv then
see had been cyber she had been stalked
uh-huh and she sort of resurfaces in
society having spent a long time out of
the the reaches of the people on the
internet or anyone that could
potentially stalk her and she starts
getting stalked again and I am the
person who's working on the case trying
to I think that I mean I honestly can't
remember but the bottom line is I
murdered her parents found her cyber
stalked her in the wheelchair but the
wheelchair turns out to be a decoy
because at the end of the movie when I
finally corner her first of all what
kind of idiot would choose in to wheel
themselves around for years just to fool
someone couldn't you put a also they
didn't have people doing like there were
no I don't think there was anybody to do
like stunt work mmm-hmm so I had to be
my own stunt people and they I have to
pull up a picture cuz you have to see it
no I they put me in a blonde wig and a
blond mustache and a blonde for the
whole movie
you can't I'm actually gonna pull up a
picture because you're going to it's
the whole thing is wet sir this is six
months ago when I say it was
character-building everyone has to start
somewhere I am very proud of the movie I
yeah are these that's me oh I don't even
know what cameras i don't even know how
these cameras even work can we wait this
was even the whole movie no this was me
for a shot where he looked like Roland I
had to I look like Ron that's actually
the birth of Roland shit
you look like David Spade in in all of
his movies so it was there was a scene
where I had to I think like it's
breaking his heart man that haircut the
Rachel
it was a ritual yeah it was a
combination between the Rachel and the
Monica dyed platinum blonde this was I
don't hate it
you're gonna send to see that but that
was me behind the scenes of this
lifetime film not enough to entice you
to my new screen finder I also had sort
of a Crispin Glover hair like hair
falling down into my fate it was can
someone Google Christian Glover because
I mix him up weapon Fisher Stevens yeah
I mix them I miss all those guys up mmm
yeah so that's he was like yeah so I had
I sort of was channeling him and it was
the first acting gig I ever did outside
of Degrassi Oh which we need to talk
about after the break did you hear us
that was oh my gosh give me all your
money coming back Laura me impressed
talking more about Kristen Kristen
Glover very excited that ritual vitamins
is a sponsor my podcast cuz I actually
take ritual vitamins I started taking
them because all of the other fish oil
capsules I was taking made me burp up
Worf smells all day I would be talking
to someone and they'd be like do you
have a goldfish in your pocket what is
that smell I was like nope sorry took
fish oil not ritual they have a little
mint capsule in there so that you
actually can take a fish oil pill and
then
frickin make out with someone within the
next six months without embarrassing
yourself from d3 to omega-3 rituals
essential for women helps fill gaps in a
woman's diet they're no Nadja capsule
designed is gentle on an empty stomach
and there's a mint tab in every bottle
what I tell you to keep things fresh so
you don't get that fishy aftertaste
common with most omega-3s for obsessive
Riedl labels all of the rituals
vegan-friendly sugar-free non-gmo
gluten-free and allergen free
ingredients and their sources are not
shady they're out there for the whole
world to see and it's a subscription so
if you forget to buy vitamins the way I
do and then start having your hair fall
out ritual is going to solve that
problem because they send it to you it's
a subscription service and you get it
every single month better health doesn't
happen overnight and right now ritual is
offering my listeners 10% off during
your first three months so fill in the
gap in your diet with essential for
women a small step that helps support a
healthy foundation for your body visit
ritual calm slash Whitney to start your
ritual today that's 10% off during your
first three months at ritual calm back /
Whitney you're welcome better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional
therapists something I don't need at all
right Benton no you get start
communicating in under 24 hours it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional counseling done securely
online there are a broad range of
expertise and better help counsellors
network which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available to clients worldwide which is
amazing you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
Benton do it now so you won't ever have
to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
with a traditional therapist better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help wants you to start
living a happier life today so visit
their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily go to
better help calm Whitney that's better
help heelp and join the over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for the good
for you podcast listeners
you guys are gonna get a 10% off
discount off your first month at better
help calm / Whitney okay I don't really
need to hear about this but since we're
best friends now I should probably know
about your Degrassi history I don't have
a rich history in de Gracia the internet
disagrees okay
I was in a movie mm-hmm I was in
Degrassi goes Hollywood did you meet
Drake I didn't meet Drake but I knew of
Drake because we both came up at the
same time I mean he far surpassed me not
in a different field um I've seen his
homes and his 747 I can confidently say
he's on a different fucking level well
maybe for now he's doing great
um okay switching gears I am very
curious about Patrick how did you find
this for the actor he just walked in to
audition
no we read who plays Patrick on my show
he was a friend he's a Canadian actor so
there's again Canada has a very simple
is a tight-knit group of friends
ultimately I had known him from a while
back
mm-hmm he was suggested by a by my
friend Stacy actually not to bring her
up again okay I get it you like more
than me really very close and you said I
knew him I knew he was a musician I knew
he was very good so I had him put
himself on tape and then instantly can I
see you a crazy question did you know
you were in a do cabaret when you cast
him no so but okay so how did you know
he was gonna be able to sing that I knew
he could sing out for just from but you
didn't know a musician okay I didn't
know he could do that mm-hmm but part of
what I love about show running is
continually pushing your actors past the
point of comfort to the point to where
they might sue you push them really push
them past they're over time yes no I
physically so I'm a monster
I knew that well the Cabaret was a
result of just knowing that I had
a cast of people who could handle it
yeah you trusted them I knew they could
pull it off cried oh I'm glad cried I
mean I'm not glad that you cried
experienced I mean I cry every night
pretty much anyway but I from Parker
right I cried when Stevie came out and
saying chills down my spine
oh and one of my favorite lions is she's
my friend died died well cry no just
thinking about it and of course the best
I cried out to I'm gonna admit it but
most people did I think did you cry at
my version or his version to version
right is that bad you know that when I
when we shot that scene hey I don't know
why I did that to myself but B how many
takes I would say three okay not bad and
we used primarily use the first one and
I'm terrible with lyrics like I'm the
person that knows the the melody but
never the lyrics and will sing like
completely wrong lines to things because
I just don't listen I guess is the
reality it took me so long just to learn
the lyrics to the song oh it's not
simply ingest I thought it was a joke
joking better than all the jazz simply
ingest like ingest me my love so that
took a long time and then I realized oh
I had to perform this so we had making
eye contact with someone making eye
contact and being very vulnerable yeah I
was I was at first it was the syringe II
cringy but in the in the most incredible
way mm-hmm and like cringe at first but
then you're like oh this is love to be
able to just totally embarrass yourself
in someone in front of someone and not
feel judged by them yeah and that was a
big turning point for the character and
I'm not usually that vulnerable to be
David for him for him to do it that's
for him to make a fool of himself like
that was so publicly it felt like such a
strong 180 arc and so earned thanks so
we did it at first I thought it was
going to be very I thought it was gonna
be a funny scene it was funny though in
it got funny and then heartbreaking and
then heartwarming and then you're crying
so we shot the first take and I had been
rehearsing to a edited version of the
song which came in at
four minutes the actual song is about
six minutes and 15 seconds so by the
time my edited version ended there was
an additional two minutes of music that
we have not accounted for and had to
continue to perform it and eventually it
was so hot in that set and I was lined
in silk right doesn't breathe hmm passed
out on the ground and then our director
came out and was sobbing
and I remember thinking I don't think
the scenes working why is this this is
not the reaction I was hoping for and I
guess it had it had moved people but
that I think is just one of those
wonderful things where at the moment
spoke for itself and I didn't intend for
that to be the case and I'm glad that it
it was well I think it's because you
were probably in it being the character
button how long we've lived with David
being covered in armor it was felt like
such a triumphant victory yeah it just
felt so triumphant
and so you were so fearless and just
sitting in the moment and making us like
sit with it and feeling you didn't like
cutaway you did well there were a lot of
that people that were like maybe you
want to tighten it up but I'm like no no
no the whole point is that it should be
about 30 seconds too long yeah it should
be like 30 seconds past the point of
comfortable that's right that's right
and it really taught me a lot about
myself because I get I have a hard time
with eye contact you probably notice
that I love oh you know sometimes I look
here okay and a lot of times I'll take a
single I buy a lot of balls a lot of
times guys get insecure because they're
like are you looking at my hairline and
I'm like no I just didn't get eye
contact as a kid has nothing to do with
your hairline like I have to explain but
it it made me realize how hard it was
for me to sit in an intimate moment
that's very hard for a lot of us yeah it
was wildly powerful I love him so much I
also love and I would love to just know
if there were other conversations around
David and Patrick in terms of how
accepting his parents were hmm that was
was there no any conversation of how
else it would have gone no I think the
big challenge I mean I sort of set out
from the very beginning to just
I've seen so many shows making fun of
small-town life right and small-town
beliefs and I really I mean we all
wanted this town to be a safe space we
wanted the town to not be the butt of
the joke right the family to be the
benefit of the joke a family and the
town to be what surrounds them and makes
them feel comfortable and seen enough to
open up and they're the judge he was so
in making that decision I knew that I
didn't want any homophobia or bigotry or
intolerance of any kind and so when it
came to doing this coming-out episode
which I I had known we were going to
write for since the season before the
challenge was how do you go about
writing a coming out episode where the
outcome is positive but you still need
stakes
you still need things to feel you know
that that keep people watching while at
the same time respecting the whole
process cuz you don't want to exploit it
for the sake of entertainment like
that's not anything that I would want to
do so it was like how do you tell an
experience that I have gone through
that's been incredibly profound and
changed me and amazing in wonderful ways
fortunately I had parents that were very
didn't bat an eye how do we tell that
story that's new and fresh and different
and the minute that we found out what if
the what if the dramatic tension was
that it's it leaked out by mistake has
Patrick had been so comfortable in the
town mm-hmm we find out that he hasn't
told his parents and then finally Johnny
tells his parents by accident and they
don't react well and the tension would
be well then why couldn't you feel
comfortable telling us exactly as
opposed to what did we do to make you
gay which I think we've seen so many
times and is is a very sort of common
reaction from a lot of parents who don't
accept their kids thing what did we do
so to play on the what did we do notion
but make them wondering or wonder what
what they did to not make him feel
comfortable enough to tell them that was
the big hook and I knew that we had a
pretty
special episode once we broke that and
realized that oh okay this is going to
be a story about acceptance and about
parents who questioned themselves as
opposed to question their their kid ah
chills chills chills tom is fine um
we're gonna do a quiz and then we're
gonna do a little lightning round okay
wait so am i I'm gonna win your quiz I'm
gonna defeat you in your own quiz okay
so we're gonna do this every episode
where you're gonna take a quiz and I'm
gonna tell you what it all means at the
end you need to tell me your favorite
animal you need to tell me your favorite
article of clothing and you need to tell
me your favorite body of water and the
three reasons why you like each one in
adjective form favorite animal don't say
your dog Thanks about it no no no what
do you mean your favorite animal in
terms of what the animal you admire like
the animal you admire the most when I
was first asked that this I went oh my
dog my dog and then I went Oh a horse
and those are things that are close to
me but in reality the animal that I love
the most is a honey badger because
they're like scrappy they're fearless
they honey badgers fight lions I'm
obsessed with I also was thinking about
dolphin but I ultimately went with honey
but I'm thinking dolphin you can do a
dolphin cosmic connection we do you know
favorite animal this would probably be
it would hear you take the thank you
that work do you need my autograph for
you yeah to actually sign this sign my
form I would say a dolphin dolphin three
adjectives why like three adjectives to
describe the dolphin like cheerful mark
smart yep caring yes I feel like
dolphins are incredibly and held captive
yeah they're very communicative
communicative but don't let me loyal
bully you loyal yeah I feel like they're
very smart caring loyal I've seen a lot
of YouTube videos of did you see that
YouTube video of the dolphin trying to
have sex with the woman yes that's not
warning horny horny
very friendly I'm scared to see where
this quiz goes your next thing is going
to beat your favorite article of
clothing and it can be anything from a
pair of socks to a sweaty toe with a
lightning bolt on it sure no that would
be David sweaters sweater but what kind
of sweater exactly a knit sweater okay
and three adjectives to describe many
sweaters okay like cozy warm you don't
let me bully you
Oh in terms of like so this has to be a
article of clothing that like that your
is your favorite so I first was gonna do
like know like a town versatile I can
switch them out yeah they can they come
in different colors comfortable mm-hmm I
ended up going with hoodie because it
was like gender neutral well the classic
timeless like I end up going with hoodie
yeah it would be a crewneck sweater okay
versatile comfortable comfortable mm-hmm
not to be confused with a mock neck no I
know I've heard and I would say what's
the opposite of intimidating inviting
inviting hmm okay favorite body of water
thank you for that you're welcome
favorite body of water this can be a
lake a lake do you have a specific one
there's any old Lake I would say Lake
Rosso where's that Terry Oh Canada just
cuz it holds a special place in my heart
mm-hmm freshwater lake and what are
three adjectives to describe this
special Lake beautiful mm-hmm
but is it like Placid is it it can be
both I feel like that's the wonderful
thing about Lakes as opposed to a pond
where you sort of know what you're
getting certain dad like yes yeah and a
foot disease seeing the bottom of it
yeah horrific monsters yeah the like I
chose the new leeches and I chose the
new river in West Virginia because it's
like sometimes calm sometimes Rapids so
what's the
beautiful it's unpredictable uh-huh
picturesque as opposed to beautiful okay
that I like the way that beautiful
sounds in regards to it to this leg
getting a lot of intel on what you're
like in the writers room and um calming
calming okay
and it's is it big yeah yeah
it's about I think it like to boat from
one end to the other is probably half an
hour are there waves can be okay
depending on the weather that's the
thing about lakes is like if it's a
computation a day usually it's it's not
gonna be quite it's not gonna be a
dramatic O'Connor
hence the unproductive sphere if a
window opens and the breeze hits your
face what are the three feelings that
you feel calm mm-hmm is it a warm breeze
it's a cool sweet spring breeze okay
calm mm-hmm safe mm-hmm at home at home
two different words because yeah I
picked I was like relieved refreshed
cleanse or something I think I was a
picture breezes I'm at my grandparents
house Oh warm nostalgic nostalgic this
is a quiz better word this is a quiz
that Freud developed that is supposed to
give an insight into people's
subconscious which I was so bad at
picking partners that my therapist made
me start giving it to people on my first
date with them to get an insight and
today I will respond to that you know
the right person movie and think it's
fun great so even asking the person to
take the clue what that's a great
philosophy great and one that I've been
struggling with that's it I just think
the RIA the realization that if you're
you have to present you your whole self
to someone and not be scared right of
the consequences right even if you
really like this person that's right the
reality is you
you don't present your whole self
authentic self you'll never have any
idea how they feel that's correct and
you can and and worse if you present an
inauthentic version of yourself and they
like that
then you're stuck attending hence my
love life then you're like a decade
you're acting on your off time terrible
thank you feeling awful and you also
feel used and kind of insecure because
basically you start thinking okay this
person likes me because of the person
I'm pretending to be and then you doubt
the relationship forever yes and you're
insecure the reality is they probably
had one foot out from the very beginning
and that's why you're not being yourself
right so my thing is take these little
quizzes and do them and if they're not
into it then they're probably not into
me anyway but do you want to know who
you are where am I
okay so we are now gonna read you the
results of who you are
they're already on your cue card no I
know this is you just are reading back
to me other thing I know
okay prescribe me prescribe me this is
an insight into your psyche this is a
way to find out who someone is nobody
wants that
they pretend to be yours actually is not
bad because normally there's a big
discrepancy you can make glasses for
this okay so your favorite animal is how
you view yourself okay okay this is good
news okay
a dolphin smart caring loyal and horny
that is the most accurate description of
myself I think I've ever heard okay I'm
back on and the article of clothing is
the way other people view you you are a
crewneck sweater that is versatile
comfortable and inviting would you say
that's how people view you inviting no
really I don't think anyone's ever
described me as an inviting presence I
find you very inviting that's so nice of
you to say I first met you I was wearing
a fanny pack and you accepted that and
you invited I don't know why you were so
sensitive about the fanny pack because I
looked we met for those times in a hotel
lobby act and we had been communicating
over social media huh and suddenly I see
you through the lobby I come over to say
hello I screamed you acted
like I walked in on you naked in a
change room it would have been way
better had you seeing me in a fanny pack
is my living nightmare
I love fanny pack I barely just started
making eye contact with you again
because of that hole keep going it was
an East pack that had paint splashes on
it I thought it looks great that was
swag the look was very hip fanny packs
are back I wearing them across their
body all laced in nothing I don't know
what does it say there about me that
you're versatile comforting Andrew but
this is how other people view you and I
think this is interesting because we are
often dysmorphic about how we're viewed
interesting interesting I think you see
yourself as not being inviting and
comfortable and versatile but other
people do and you know that on some
level and usually the way when my
friends are listening to this being like
absolutely not
I am you know what I'll take that yeah
you're gonna you don't decide how you
isn't about me anymore you don't get to
decide how you're perceived but it's
interesting to know like I used to think
that everybody thought that I was a
bitch but everyone like no one thinks
that of you I just thought that's what I
was exerting because I had some weird
dysmorphia I think the total opposite
see I think it's important that we know
how we're perceived because there's a
discrepancy between how we think we're
perceived and how we actually are
perceived which usually this comes up
yours actually wasn't that different
because mine was honey badger like which
is like ferocious blood sucking scrappy
and then my favorite article of clothing
was hoody which is inviting warm and
comforting like the way I see myself is
very different than the way people see
me and I think that that sometimes
that's helpful and something that's
helpful to quiz people on a first date
to find out what you're dealing with
favor body water is how you view sex
unpredictable calming and picturesque
okay that's the snag in this that's the
major snag now you imagine describing
your sex life as picturesque you're very
I'm not okay I mean cinematic no I feel
like there's probably a picture s my
naked body Bobby Bobby
thing around that made you nervous it's
picturesque I bet I bet you're very good
at long you're very elegant and good at
blocking I feel like there's an elegance
with which you conduct yourself in them
you know that the next time I'm working
up with someone I'm gonna be thinking
about this the entire time about Lake
Rosie picturesque beef picturesque
second in second and then the way the
way that you react to a window opening
with the cool breeze coming in is how
you view death and yours is pretty sane
calm safe nostalgic at home if I'm
welcoming it as if you're looking
forward to it quite frankly I don't ever
think about it which is probably why I
have such a neutral approach to it right
a lot of people on this one there's as
like anxious scared unnerved people come
up with a lot of weird shit but that's
worth knowing about somebody and their
subconscious because if I were to ask
you these questions directly we probably
wouldn't have answers and I mean this
could be phooey
I mean Freud had a lot of really I feel
good about most of takes
I mean Freud had some very but for
example if you're on a date and you ask
them in their favorite animal if they
say like leech get the fuck out of there
can you imagine being on a date and
asking them what your favorite animal is
it happened they say I know someone that
this happened to and I hold the police
Oh once say bear because they're like
fearless and like loners it was that it
was like they're low you're gonna say
and would tear you open from top to tail
and like sleep for eight months I was
like this is a red flag all over the
place so take it with a grain of salt
last thing I'm gonna ask you oh I don't
want to attend red flags your big red
flags about myself
no just can I know what should be deep
dive can you tell me that to tell you
this very clearly in really when you
meet someone and go to red flag I'm
trying to it because this podcast is so
good for you I want everyone to glean
something out of this any major red
flags that our listeners slash viewers
should take note of I guess if I were to
analyze my love life mm-hmm all the
times when I didn't feel good were times
where I was compromising my
sense of self and I realized I think it
comes with age and I think it comes with
realizing that you can only push
yourself so far into relationships where
you don't feel valued then you have to
seek something more fulfilling right I
love that you're saying that because I
think a lot of people when you talk
about red flags people say what's going
on with the other person like if their
screensaver is a picture of themself all
about you that is a reputable maybe it's
because I'm I've been single for a long
time and I really enjoy being single and
I love my independence and I've built a
nice life for myself so I don't I don't
have the same need to couple up right
even more the reason to he'd red flags
quickly astronaut way stuff but I do
feel like if I'm not being myself with
someone and if I feel like something
about the dynamic is hurting my heart or
making me feel bad it's not worth it
like I find if I'm laughing at someone's
jokes and they're not funny that's a red
flag oh yeah that means I'm performing
I'm being fake that's bone-chilling to
me and I've done it a lot
I've dated some people that are funny
but that's okay I find them hysterical
you end up having like a out-of-body
experience huh you're like astral
projected out of yourself looking down
being like why am i doing because then
you're walking on eggshells trying to
take care of their ego or some and
you're only fostering more bad jokes
yeah you're encouraging it so they're
just gonna keep bobbing they're fun oh
god and then you're a live studio
audience member oh god you're on a
multicam and the audience and it's a
nightmare cause that's a very good red
flag if you find yourself being
inauthentic or if you're just tired all
the time that probably means you're
being drained I think you're trying any
you know couple that has been together
for a long time they make each other
better and yeah every day as hard as it
is they go to bed happy to be with the
person and feeling good about themselves
I think a good red flag is people that
talk shit about their exes that's a red
flag to me Oh yuck and if they don't
have exes that's a whole other bag
that's a whole other thing but
people to call their ex is crazy or
psychos I don't like any of that shit
you should feel good about yourself yeah
and you're dating someone concur and if
you're not news flash not the right
person yeah
concur have you gotten any very good
pieces of advice you want to share with
everyone I had its advice that I wrote
for a character on my show like advice
on I wish you had gotten at 22 there's a
scene on my show and I'm not saying this
to be egotistical because I mean we've
met I'm literally couldn't laugh it's
wild but like if there was a moment when
I was writing the scene and it was a
driving test between and David was
getting scared for his driving test and
Alexis is in the car and she says to him
David nobody thinks about you the way
that you think about you and I don't
know where the line came from maybe it's
maybe I needed it somehow or maybe I had
I mean I failed my driving test 11 times
more times than David dead 11 times this
is why we don't even have time on this
podcast for stories of how many times I
failed and I'm a good driver I have
terrible test anxiety that's what it can
just get nervous and I guess having to
think about that moment having to are
having to write the dialogue for that
scene it just came out the line sort of
just came out with me onto the page and
it I was like oddly impressed with
myself because I was like that's great
advice for Alexis and I love writing
Alexis because I feel like she's had so
many insane experiences that her advice
is actually great right it's often
really good he's been kidnapped
everywhere hidden like in hostage crazy
100% and that was a piece of advice that
that somehow manifested itself in me
that I essentially I guess told myself
and the reality is nobody thinks about
you the way that you think about you all
the worries that you have about being
perceived and how you look or what
people are going to think people have
other lives people are busy no but to me
cares I have good news and I have bad
notes nobody's thinking about
yeah absolutely like we obsess over what
someone thinks about us until we know
what it cares about you yeah in that
sense but where everybody cares but
nobody cares quite as much as you think
they care we're like I'm a piece of shit
in the center of the universe everyone's
talking about how much of a piece of
shit I am mm-hmm all day every day
they're probably talking to their
friends about it journey yeah when I
leave in exchange and I'm like I shoulda
said that that was so stupid they're
doing that oh no they're not thinking
about to dinner with their family and I
am panicked no they're chosen a wrong
word in a conversation they're checking
who viewed their Instagram stories
meanwhile I'm like gosh I apologize I'll
apologize to people for things I'm like
so I'm sorry that came out wrong and
they're like all have that ability it's
like don't even remember discussing it
don't even remember discussing it but I
think that's why you're a good writer an
actor yeah be gentle with yourself we're
so mean to ourselves sometimes yuck pet
peeves give any pet peeves I have a
couple pet peeve astrological sign
cruelty pet peeves gross people being
rude to people in the service industry
it's got teeth no way no um these head
moans um when people dress act that i
just spray it snot all over myself I
didn't see that oh really last pet peeve
it's all you're thinking about I know it
bad Halloween costumes ah particularly
when people do like a really bad like
swinging sixties costume you mean bad as
in they phoned it in or bad in like like
not a right wife if you're gonna do like
Austin Powers like era nail it nail it
well there's or supplies a bag over your
body and go as a plastic bag do you
don't I'm saying this is such a funny
really executed Halloween costumes and
the bottom line is I don't go out a lot
for Halloween I will I have not gone out
for Halloween because I haven't had a
good enough costume idea although I
don't see very good shits Creek costumes
on your I've entered my favorite thing
the best chair there's just a lot of
drama
there's people there like completely
spit across the table or so there were
people that it was like Groucho Marx it
was like someone took a thick black
sharpie and just scribbled repeatedly
over their eye for like people took
cartoon mustaches like two of them 100
snipped a mustache in half and just glue
the first provide a lot of questions
about it people want to know what you do
to them nothing don't trim that we trim
occasionally you don't die then you
don't know Brazilian straightening
oh yes the Brazilian straightening like
a flat Nate like it's just flat iron
nothing people really want to know what
I will say if I fall asleep face-first
on my pillow I have to do I had to do
electrolysis between my eyebrows you're
very thin brows though you think yeah oh
because I used to shave them and they
didn't grow back for a while shave yeah
I shaved them when I was a kid because I
had a unit and I was so embarrassed and
I shaved them but now Benton showed me
how to fill them in with a pencil I know
someone that took hair from their head
and made them eyebrows that's a
procedure is that person well uh
touching oh okay touching go okay yeah
it's tricky and then and they have to
cut them so that I want a big girl like
human hairy chest hair uh-huh when I was
a teenager and now there's a thicker
patch of hair on my stomach where I
shaved from when I was about twice as
much that's why you're out there
wondering how to groom themselves do not
shave do not just a patch and it was
just a patch cuz I did it and was like
no mistake did you go against the grain
no it was just a dumb like guys if you
have body hair embrace your body hair
and add the people you're with are
shaming you for having body hair because
we're living in a plastic society where
apparently yeah hair growing out of a
human being is a strange and terrible
thing right that goes somewhere else I
surround yourself with people who can
behind you because we only got one life
and if you have body hair just shame and
graphene in Benton has your body hair
situation you have my tralala see
Madison you're not helping how did you
you undermined everything that our gas
literally dead lean in to your body
where Oh like Oh on your shoulders a
little electrolysis on the shoulders is
fine not mad about that
actually I'm when you said one part of
your body I got scared
time's up on me sorry oh god I'm gonna
get stiff Benton what if he wants to sue
me I will have no money left and then
you asked if you will get this entire
house that's one part of his body house
what is it what's the part oh my god
what if he says the part that I'm
thinking what a nice heart now you can
one part back away slow ball is plural
was it the part I was thinking oh my god
thank god you're not a terrible you're
not my assistant anymore so you can't
sue me you were technically a co-worker
I've talked to service manager thought
about lower I was thinking lower back
see okay we're in a Nashville mini mall
here here I don't know where you get
most money to get electrolysis I thought
you worked at Sephora wait they have
pens not two they have pens now that are
like electrolysis pens that are I get it
online don't offer to me on Instagram no
doing me just saying get that in the
black toothpaste
I feel like soon enough like in the next
come in the coming years there will be
proper pens just to do it yourself
yeah yeah I heard I on I don't don't do
it my gynecologist told me that because
I got laser back in the day laser to
everything off okay and I am freezing
and I asked her about it because then it
starts to grow back like weird like
Smithers like just to hair like it's
just dye Smithers is a word that is like
readily descriptive everyone knows
exactly what you're saying with Smithers
as strange and roundabout is that where
it is I like things
be picturesque as do and I went to my
gynecologist I was like is there any way
to like get it back because I feel like
you couldn't you put this body waste
back in what do they people do with
their eyelashes uh like false eyelashes
no there's like like Oh last teeth yeah
well changes the color of your eye a
friend or Chimel did less tease mm-hmm
Latisse letís I don't know I don't know
we better buy a hit it and then had a
cry forgot that she was had to Latisse
on No and then there was hair growing
out of her the tear that's not No
correct this is not first hand cut to
sued by letís to Benton letís now my
home that's what I need I have to finish
this oh because we at the gynecologists
office
she said that women are now coming in
getting plugs that lasered 20 years ago
and now want pubes back and they're
getting plugs aren't plugs like
unbelievably painful not there yet the
technology's not there yet it don't do
it I'm doing it and it's sketchy I'm
sorry you have guy friends i inserting
pubic hair back oh no the hair plugs on
the head the baby's not gonna tell me
which I moved back up you have some kind
of Ohio nothing about anything but if
you were to losing your hair how would
putting a bit in front of your receding
hairline prevent that from you just grow
it long and comb it you just basically
it's a scalp transplant you're not
necessarily selling me on you will never
need it you have a comically perfect
hairline but that really woke up the
hair was very high today yeah I love it
it's very like um I don't know what it
looks like I love it so much it's
incredibly thick you're taking those
omegas I wish those omegas I'm eating
those there's like gummies and stuff
that you can take now um CBD dummy's no
they're like gummy vitamins um ease
right okay we'll talk about that stop
stop taking random I don't know I got it
electrolysis pens gummy no I'm taking
them religion okay we get it you were
her tummy we got it you get gift bags
got it okay someone gets get back same
gift bag I got four years ago at some
sort of event do you have any questions
for me how are you doing I'm doing okay
how's your heart dead okay black cool
song shrunken good for you good for you
do you think it's the inflection is good
for you good for you good for you it
should be good for you I think it's an
it's like it is like a confident good
for you do you think it's a good title I
think it's a great title but I think it
should be good for you but also the kind
of people that show the person that's
gonna save have you heard good for you
peaking of like a like a Freudian round
up the people they say good for you the
bitchiest just to talk to them about
things the bitchiest people I know think
it's good for you they're like that's
such a funny title I'm like mmm so
Rorschach test you failed Oh like like a
sarcastic like good for you oh no yeah
see cuz you're not a monster I thought
it was like good for you like we can do
it we can't yeah do it together
yes and this podcast is good for you
don't you think people got something out
of this yes if anything how to get
vaginal plugs that's now on your radar
it's good for you good for you good for
us we did it oh but I want to tell you
something really quick this is important
this is important and this is not an ad
but I wanted you to know that in your
honor we're doing something very special
with this pod so the cash app is
donating for every time someone and I
already did this ad you have heard it
another time every time you don't donate
not true every time that you download
the cash app they're gonna donate ten
dollars to The Trevor Project and honor
of Dan let me come on the rest of time
for the rest of the whole podcast
forever what good for me good for
everyone good for them good for us
amazing organization provides crisis
intervention and suicide prevention
services to LGBTQ youth across America
that does so when you guys all Uwe Boll
lifeline I chose that I probably should
have let you choose it
no that's what a good patty I feel like
it's on your brand to just bully Oh with
these charity edges
here's your charity hope it works with
your brand hope it's on brand yeah I
couldn't think of a better charity thank
you so much so forever forever that is
what they're gonna match that donation
forever and ever for the rest of our
podcast like a wonderful way to sign off
I'm not excited it is yeah
love you good for us good
[Music]